'.
>> RATHER THAN HAVING ISRAEL'S
BACK, SENIOR DEMOCRATS HAVE
ACTUALLY PRESSURED ISRAEL TO END
ITS DEFENSIVE OPERATIONS.
THEY HAVE CALLED FOR A
CEASE-FIRE AND URGED LEADERS TO
STRIVE FOR PEACE THROUGH A
NEGOTIATED TWO-STATE SOLUTION.
>> NETANYAHU IS OUT THERE SAYING
THAT HE HAS A BLANK CHECK FROM
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S WHAT HE IS SAYING.
HE SAID THIS IS GOING TO GO ON
FOR MORE TIME AND THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS -- NO WE ARE
NOT.
MANY MEMBERS OF COMING,
INCLUDING SUPPORTERS OF THE U.S.
ISRAEL RELATIONSHIP LIKE MYSELF
AND OTHERS WHO ARE SAYING THAT
NETANYAHU DOES NOT HAVE A BLANK
CHECK.
>> Bret: WELL, THE WHITE HOUSE
DEAL ARE VERY VOCAL MEMBERS OF
THEIR DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS UP ON
THE HILL ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
ISRAEL, IT ACTIONS AGAINST
HAMAS.
THE WHITE HOUSE PUTTING OUT A
READOUT THE CALL WITH THE
ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SPOKE WITH
ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER BENJAMIN
NETANYAHU TODAY THE TWO HAD A
DISCUSSION ON THE STATE OF
EVENTS IN GAZA, THE CAPABILITIES
OF HAMAS AND OTHER TERRORIST
ELEMENTS AND REGIONAL
DEVELOPMENTS BY THE PRESIDENT
AND THE UNITED STATES.
THE PRESIDENT CONVEYED TO THE
PRIME MINISTER THAT HE EXPECTED
A SIGNIFICANT DEESCALATION TODAY
ON THE PATH TO A CEASE-FIRE.
NO INDICATION YET THAT THAT HAS
HAPPENED.
LET'S SEE IF IT DOES.
LET WANTS BRING IN OUR PANEL
BILL BENNETT FORMER EDUCATION
SECRETARY, HOST OF THE BILL
BENNETT SHOWED PODCAST.
AUTHOR OF THE BOOK MADAM SPEAKER
AND BEN DOMENECH PLUSH
EVERYWHERE OF THE FEDERALIST.
SUSAN, SPEAKING ABOUT SPEAKER
PELOSI, SHE IS HAVING TO KIND OF
LET HER CAUCUS SPEAK ITS MIND ON
THIS FOREIGN POLICY ISSUE.
BUT, THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SEEMS TO BE TRYING TO TIP TOE
THROUGH ALL OF THAT.
>> I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN HAD
HOPED TO BE AS LITTLE ENGAGED IN
THIS AS POSSIBLE.
HE CERTAINLY HASN'T BEEN AS
OUTSPOKEN AS SOME EVEN IN HIS
OWN PARTY HAD HOPED HE WOULD BE.
GOT A LITTLE FARTHER FORWARD
TODAY IN HIS CONVERSATION WITH
NETANYAHU.
OF COURSE, DEMOCRATS ARE DIVIDED
ON THE ISSUE OF THE CONFLICT
BETWEEN ISRAELIS AND
PALESTINIANS AND THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER ON THE
PROGRESSIVE SIDE WHO THINKS THE
UNITED STATES SHOULD DO MUCH
MORE TO PROTECT PALESTINIANS
EVEN AT THE COST OF PRESSURING
OUR LONG-TIME ALLY ISRAEL.
IT IS A DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
AND IT'S ONE THAT I THINK PELOSI
IS WELL AWARE OF BECAUSE SHE HAS
ALL THESE DIFFERENT VOICES IN
OTHER OWN CAUCUS.
>> Bret: BEN, REPUBLICANS
OBVIOUSLY ARE JUMPING ON THIS
SAYING THAT THERE IS A HAMAS
CAUCUS WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
>> IT IS NOT A DIFFICULT
SITUATION FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT OUGHT TO STAND
WITH ISRAEL AS AMERICA'S LONG
TIME ALLY IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
BUT, UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK WE
SEE A SITUATION HERE THAT THE
IRANIANS ARE LOOKING TO EXPLOIT.
THEY HAVE BEEN ON THEIR HEELS,
THANKS TO THE LAST FOUR YEARS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, WHICH
SAW THEM REALLY HURT IN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS BOTH, YOU KNOW,
IT HAS SEEN THE TOP OF THEIR
MILITARY EXERCISE, YOU KNOW,
ESSENTIALLY KNOCKED OFF, THANKS
TO BOTH THE ISRAELIS AND THE
AMERICANS, BUT, ALSO, I THINK
THEY SEE A SITUATION WHERE THEY
ARE TRYING TO SEIZE THIS MOMENT
TO LEAN IN TO THIS NEW
ADMINISTRATION WHICH HAS A LOT
OF DISTRUST WITH ISRAEL AND
ABOUT B. NETANYAHU.
AND IN TRYING TO ESSENTIALLY
ATTAIN A NEW DYNAMIC THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO RESTORE WHAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO DO BACK IN 2015.
UNFORTUNATELY, I THINK WE ARE
SEEING A SITUATION WHERE THE
INCOMPETENCE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEIR
INCONSISTENCY WHEN IT COMES TO
FOREIGN POLICY IS LEADING TO
BENEFITS FOR OUR ENEMIES
OVERSEAS.
>> Bret: BILL, THERE ARE SOME
EXPERTS, FOREIGN POLICY EXPERTS
NOT JUST REPUBLICANS WHO SAY
THIS ALL POINTS TO IRAN AND ITS
ABILITY TO FUNNEL FUNDS TO HAMAS
AND TO PRODUCE THIS MOMENT.
>> WELL, CERTAINLY THE FUNDS
THAT WENT TO IRAN WERE USED TO
MAKE THESE ROCKETS, WHICH ARE
BEING LAUNCHED INTO ISRAEL.
AND I THINK B.B. NETANYAHU WILL
STAND HIS GROUND, AS I KNOW HIM,
HE WILL.
BUT, FURTHER, WE ARE NOW TALKING
ABOUT GIVING IRAN MORE MONEY.
REMEMBER, GOING BACK TO THE
TABLE, WHICH MEANS POTENTIALLY
FUELING MORE OF THIS.
GIVING THEM MORE FUNDS TO
PRODUCE MORE ROCKETS.
I WILL SPLIT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN SUSAN AND BEBB.
I AGREE WITH BEN IT'S NOT
DIFFICULT IN TERMS OF RIGHT AND
WRONG HERE.
WHO STARTED THIS FIGHT AND WHY
DID THEY START IT BECAUSE THEY
THINK THERE SHOULD BE AN END TO
THE STATE OF ISRAEL.
BUT IT'S A DIFFICULT SITUATION
FOR BIDEN BECAUSE HE DOESN'T
KNOW WHAT HE THINKS.
HE IS BEING PRESSURED BY THE
LEFT CAUCUS AND, OF COURSE HE
ALSO WANTS TO KEEP GOOD
RELATIONS WITH OUR GREATEST ALLY
IN THE WORLD.
B.B. NETANYAHU KNOWS WHO HE IS.
KNOWS WHAT HE WANTS TO DO, BIDEN
IS IN THE PROCESS OF FIGURING IT
OUT.
WELCOME TO THE JOB,
MR. PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: MEANTIME NORD STREAM 2
PIPELINE UNDER CONSTRUCTION,
RUSSIA DESPERATELY WANTS IT
COMPLETED TO GO INTO GERMANY.
THERE IS A LOT OF THOUGHT ABOUT
IT AS YOU LOOK AT THE GRAPHIC OF
WHERE IT GOES.
IT'S NOT FINISHED YET.
THERE WERE STIFF SANCTIONS THAT
ARE BEING LIFTED ON THE COMPANY
THAT'S CONSTRUCTING IT.
AND THERE IS SOME REACTION TO
ALL OF THAT.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SOON IS GOING TO BE
RELEASING A REPORT REGARDING THE
MANDATORY SANCTIONS THAT
CONGRESS HAS IMPOSED AND
ASSISTING ON THE BUILDING OF
NORD STREAM 2, SO, AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IS GOING TO NOTIFY
CONGRESS SOON.
>> I WOULD LOVE TO SEE THE
ARGUMENT HOW THIS WAIVER WHICH
BENEFITS SEEMINGLY TO ME,
BENEFITS ONLY VLADIMIR PUTIN, --
BY NOT COMPLETING THE LAST
100 YARDS OF THE KEYSTONE
PIPELINE.
SO I DON'T QUITE FOLLOW, HAVE
THAT WAIVER OF THE NATIONAL
INTEREST OCCURS.
>> Bret: SUSAN, HOW ABOUT THIS
HOW IT PLAYS?
>> BILL BENNETT SAID WELCOME TO
THE JOB, MR. PRESIDENT.
IT IS TRUE THAT THE JOB IS A
TOUGH ONE, INVOLVES BALANCING
INTEREST.
THIS IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THIS IS NOT INTENDED AS A
DECISION TO HELP RUSSIA.
THAT'S A SIDE EFFECT.
THIS IS INTENDED AS A DECISION
TO HELP GERMANY, WHICH WANTED
VERY MUCH THE COMPLETION OF THE
PIPELINE.
IT PUTS THE ADMINISTRATION IN
THIS AWKWARD SITUATION WHICH WE
HAVE HEARD ABOUT, TONY BLINKEN
WHICH HE WAS IN HIS CONFIRMATION
HEARINGS SECRETARY OF STATE SAYS
THE UNITED STATES THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD ACTIVELY
OPPOSE COMPLETION OF THIS
PIPELINE BUT I THINK WHEN THE
BALANCE OF INTEREST CAME OUT
THEY CAME OUT IN A DIFFERENT
POSITION ON THAT.
AND SO RUSSIA REASONS THE
BENEFITS OF THE DESIRE OF
GERMANY TO GET THIS PIPELINE
COME COMPLETED.
>> Bret: THAT IS WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SAYING, BUT IT
IS INTERESTING IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE GERMAN ELECTIONS ARE COMING.
ANGELA AMERICA'S TERM AS
CHANCELLOR IS GOING TO BE OVER
COME SEPTEMBER.
AND THE LEADING PARTY IS THE
GREEN PARTY WHICH ACTUALLY IS
OPPOSED TO NORD STREAM 2 IN
GERMANY.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE ALL
KINDS OF THINGS HAPPENING
POTENTIALLY IN COMING MONTHS.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF MOVING PARTS
HERE.
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
WE REALLY HAVE TO APPRECIATE
ABOUT THIS DECISION IS THAT IT
REALLY UNDERMINES NATO IN A LOT
OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
IT DOES NOT SERVE OUR INTEREST
IN TERMS OF BENEFITING RUSSIA'S
ABILITY TO INFLUENCE EUROPE.
AND I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT OBVIOUSLY PRESIDENT
BIDEN RAN ON AS A CANDIDATE WAS
HIS CRITICISM OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AS BEING TOO SOFT
ON RUSSIA IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
RESPECTS.
YOU CAN DEBATE WHETHER THAT WAS
TRUE, BUT FROM MY PERSPECTIVE,
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IN THE EARLY
DAYS FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT INDICATES A
HARD LINE TOWARD RUSSIA.
I WILL BE VERY CURIOUS TO SEE IF
IN THEIR CONVERSATION VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND JOE BIDEN IN THE
COMING WEEK IF THEY HAVE ANY
KIND OF CONVERSATION THAT
INCLUDES THE NAME IN A VAN ANY.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK
MAY NOT HAPPEN AND IF THAT DOES
NOT HAPPEN, IT'S AN INDICATION
THAT THIS IS AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IS NOT WILLING TO REALLY
STAND UP AND HOLD THE RUSSIAN'S
FEET TO THE FIRE.
>> Bret: OPPOSITION LEADER IN
RUSSIA AGAINST PUTIN.
VERY QUICKLY, BILL, THIS STORY
AGAINST SENATOR SASSE HAVING A
PROBLEM IN GRILLING THIS NOMINEE
FOR GENERAL COUNSEL FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE BECAUSE HE DID WORK
FOR HUAWEI, THE CHINESE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANY THAT
HAS BEEN UNDER FIRE AND UNDER
SANCTION BY THE U.S.
IF THROUGH THE PRISM OF THIS
HAPPENED IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, HOW WOULD IT
LOOK TONIGHT?
>> WELL, EVERYTHING WOULD LOOK
DIFFERENT AND TO THE MEDIA
EVERYTHING WOULD BE DIFFERENT.
BEN SASSE CAN BE VERY WRONG IN
MY VIEW.
CAN BE OUT ON A LIMB SOMETIMES.
BUT TODAY OR YESTERDAY HE WAS
RIGHT.
THIS VERY EXPERIENCED WASHINGTON
HAND, THIS LAWYER ACTING AS IF,
YOU KNOW, HE WAS JUST HELPING
WITH ADMINISTRATIVE RULES, WHEN
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE RULES ARE
THINGS THEY CAN GET AROUND, SO
HUAWEI CAN CONTINUE ITS EFFORTS
AND, REMEMBER, THIS IS A REGIME
THAT PERSECUTE THE UYGHURS AND
WE KNOW ABOUT HUAWEI'S ROLE IN